in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Charles
and Tricia are with us hey guys how are
you hi we're good hey welcome where're
you guys from
we're from Centerville Minnesota just
Twin Cities area oh yeah very cool
that's a long way to Nashville good
Drive yeah and here to do a debt-free
scream absolutely yes how much have you
paid off so we have paid off fifty four
thousand seven hundred and seventeen
dollars excellent
and how long did that take thirty eight
months Wow
and your household income during that
time so we started at ninety five
thousand and finished at 110,000 nice
what are you two do for a living I am a
project manager for a medical device
company mm-hm
and I'm a marriage and family therapist
very cool good for you guys and the two
young men with you your sons I swim how
old are they whether the name Trenton is
12 and Logan is 8 very cool okay very
good so what kind of debt was the
$55,000
that was our mortgage you paid off your
house we paid off our house weird people
that's fun that wasn't much of a
mortgage you'd already paid it way down
yes very good very cool so how what's
the house worth probably high to 200s
okay they're around two to three hundred
and okay excellent
very nice house how old are you guys I'm
45 46 any a paid-for house yes I mean
you're just straight-up weird we are how
long have y'all been married 22 years
like should be 22 years on Friday good
for you very fun have you ever been dead
for a since you got married no other
than right at the beginning of this we
were actually we're debt-free
consumer debt before we took financial
piece so that was kind of we were though
unique that way yeah you were already
cooking it so is that what happened 38
months ago you went through the class
you went okay ding ding we're gonna
knock the house out yeah yeah
was a little different than that we the
class wasn't even entirely intentional
the kids were in a musical church and
they were offering it during the times
they had practice so we were very
interested in we took it but there was a
lot of life that happened during that
time too we ended up we were just at
favorite free but we hadn't yet really
pumped up our emergency fund really
heavily in that meantime Charles ARS
also published a book which we paid part
of the publishing costs on that we
bought a car I mean there was a lot of
other life that happened during that
time too so it really was more like a
year and a half ago that we really got
intense around the mortgage piece so
you're chipping away at it around these
other things but then when that stuff
cleared you went okay game on
yeah i'm-a got more serious about you
know it's building up you know financial
reserve and everything else to emergency
plan your that's not your other than the
fifty five thirty eight months ago but
somewhere during the process do you
remember the time that month that you
sat down and you went we're gonna build
a that we're almost we're gonna do this
you could see it you know I'm talking
about it was like an reach you remember
what that was and what the amount was at
that point boy it's an emotional thing
innit because I started really listening
to you more watching things like the
debt-free screams on YouTube I remember
being our bed with a tablet and just
playing with in mortgage numbers and be
like okay what if I put added this to
that or what if we did that yeah and I
think that's where it was really that
that's when it comes real
thirty-thousand I can't remember exactly
at some point it was like okay if we
just do this you have a nice smile
moment though where you go you know you
just like it was intellectual before
that and then suddenly clicks
emotionally that it's going to happen
right yes that can be us to moment I
think is just great
yeah that's to moment that's a good way
of saying yeah good for you guys what
you were tracking it you knew us too
intellectually but I'm just saying some
point as you're rolling along you're
going way minutes right there that's
really good this kind of breakthrough
things I remember that distinctly
well congratulations things have changed
your family tree miss amazing
and the you know the young men their
lives are changed because the math is
going to change in your all's life from
this point forward I mean millions of
millions of dollars without a doubt
making the kind of money you make and
not a payment in the world if you do
some investing and still do outrageous
generosity you're gonna have that kind
of money it's gonna change your all's
lives I mean your old man old lady
Vanderbilt you're changing the whole
thing here this is pretty cool and you
teach the young guys how to handle money
so they got some sense and I suspect
you're doing that oh yes he was in there
right now reading the junior books in
the in the back of there that's awesome
very cool well very good we're gonna
give you guys a cos on copy of Chris
Hogan's number one bestseller retire
inspired cuz that's the next step now I
mean you finish this part of the story
go on to the next part and that's
finished building the wealth now because
now you're free very cool very very cool
all right have the guys been practicing
their dead free scream very much
practice we just really don't want wimpy
that free scream for the kids we say one
thing just about the whole freedom
component yes oh yeah I think that was
really one thing that clinched it for us
you know we started to realize that you
know you don't have to have a car
payment you don't have to have a house
payment you know you can talk you can
really you know tell your money where to
go I think some of the stuff so
prevalent in our culture and I think for
us just we're just excited to be free
you know and hopefully not give more but
then hopefully inspire other people too
we just think about you know and just in
the age we live in if believers can be
you know set free and not have debt and
be able to give more money and yep more
cause than just kind of a powerful
impact oh the if I mean think about this
what if two out of every ten Christians
didn't have a house payment and gave
their house payment away mm-hmm in the
name of Jesus what that would do to our
culture we share that that's so much
money it's unbelievably much money that
else trillions of dollars you can stand
a whole economy on its head with that
one idea so you're exactly right you're
onto something I mean the math when you
go macro on this huh it's mind-blowing
what the spiritual impact of
that kind of generosity would be and
we're heading there one at a time
there's another one right here I love it
you guys are great Charles and Tricia
Trenton Logan Trenton and Logan $55,000
paid off in 38 months that's their house
and everything baby-making 95 to 110
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream that's how it's done
right there man doesn't get any better
than that folks so you're listening to
that you're watching that on the live
YouTube stream we're on the Dave Ramsey
show channel with the app my only
question is when are you gonna do this
yeah I'm talking to you
why are you screwing around being like
everybody else don't live a mediocre
life I'll be mediocre be excellent don't
be typical typical stroke normal sucks
don't be normal be like those guys you
can do this
welcome to you this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income a $500,000 in the car
you